它记录到2016年到2025年这10年的平均的全球升温。
相对于1850到1900年这个平均温度。
升温达到了1.26摄氏度。
其中人类贡献是1.24摄氏度。
而且朱克人先生通过古籍中他得到的这个结论。
跟后来大家就是科学家从北极格林兰群岛的这个冰星里面。
得到的训练非常的一致。
您在科普节目里可能也第一次听到。
原来这种气象的天气的最终给我们的这个判断。
是有很多真人在那儿博弈和会商出来的结果。
如此短的时间内温度升高了这么多。
就这个升温速率历史上是从来没有过的。
这是我们现在最担心的。
好各位博物聊天中心的听众朋友们。
大家好
我是老信我们又回来了。
咱们今天聊一个今年特别让大家瞩目的话题。
就是关于天气气候这个话题。
那么我们先来介绍二位嘉宾。
这今天的二位嘉宾可能是大名头。
都是从咱们中国气象局系统请来的二位专家老师。
我们请到了国家气候中心的高级工程师邵鹏诚老师。
少说给大家打个招呼。
大家好
我是国家气候中心邵鹏诚。
好
还有一位是来自中国气象局气象宣传与科普中心的高级工程师崔国辉老师。
大家好
我是崔国辉
好
首先特别感谢这个二位老师以及中国气象局的老师的协助。
因为其实我们这次还挺冒昧的。
因为想聊这个主题。
大家可能看到了我们杂志7月份8月份也都是和气象有关的主题。
但是我们杂志的主题可能更偏向大家科普。
一些原理
一些打气物理的这些知识。
我们播贺节目轻松我就想到了和气象局的老师聊了。
这比较好
所以我们虽然还是有认识朋友介绍。
但几乎就是直接拍门找人。
特别感谢气象局的咱们科普中心的老师一听。
兄弟将单位搞科普。
这我们全力支持
其实说起来今天这期也挺波折的。
本来计划是周三路。
结果这一个礼拜北京是红色天气玉井。
要下大暴雨
说别大暴雨
二位老师在港岛杂志社也不方便。
说咱们错一天
错的周四
结果昨天我一看我就毁了。
没下
说完了明天要下大雨。
也就是我们录制的今天要下大雨。
可怎么办
结果今天早上起来一看。
想情白日
这我就得问问二位老师了。
作为中国气象的number one。
以及气象预报的源头。
这咋回事
预报的红色咋没下。
没有
其实昨天早上雨下来还是非常大的。
然后对枣高峰的影响也非常大。
如果是昨天录制的话。
确实会有一些影响。
可能到9点10点。
这个交通还是会比较拥堵的一个情况。
就是说预报准不准的问题。
其实北京是提前是发了暴雨的红色玉井。
然后我们从实况来看的话。
其实在一些山区
确实达到暴雨量级了。
然后昨天早上其实雨也是下得非常大。
大家是能够直观地感受到暴雨的。
但是可能大家理解的暴雨的话。
它可能持续一天都是下得特别大。
但其实它是一个24小时的一个累计雨量。
它从整个面雨量上来看的话。
是达到暴雨量级了。
就说咱报的还是挺准的。
确实是
而且可能像北京地方也挺大。
每个地儿的降雨的情况也不一样。
大家体感上可能会有点区别。
那么正常的天气预报。
确实都是从咱们气象局。
还是气象中心这边给的数据。
然后电视台去报的。
因为我知道那个录制的场地。
就在咱们气象局里边好像。
中央电视台的天气预报的话。
是在咱们中国气象局的华峰。
也是集团去录制的。
然后各地的话也是气象部门。
去提供这些预报的数据。
然后可能是当地的这种主持人。
去建想播报
那其实从全国的预报来看的话。
就是从咱们中国气象局出去的。
然后咱们这种各种的APP的数据。
它其实也是采集的。
中国气象局去发布的这些数据。
然后自己的话也会有一些。
这种AI的模型
然后去做出这种适合手机端的用户。
更适合去看的这些页面。
然后去查看的天气预报。
等于原数据
这个全位数据都是。
确实从咱们国家气象局。
中国气象局出来的。
明白
那咱们既然说到这个叫什么？
极端天气
或者说老百姓话
怪天
确实我从老百姓我们提改上说。
今年怪天是挺怪的。
而且不光中国怪
全世界都怪
二位老师有这个感觉。
或者从科学上说
确实咱们先聊这么一个。
严尔伟的专业上讲。
啥叫极端天气
极端天气
你从专业的角度
它其实就是小概率事件。
像在讲这个之前的话。
我们其实有的时候很容易混淆。
什么是天气
什么是气候
这是两个不同的概念。
太多了
像天气的话
我们就是当下
我们实实在在感受到的。
比如昨天夜里下雨了。
今天早上夜阳高照。
这就是天气
它是一个比较短的时间。
可能是几天以内
这样一个实实在在的大气的一个状况。
它的变化是非常快的。
音清鱼血变化幅度是比较大的。
那么气候它是一个长时间尺度的。
一般上标准是用30年平均。
说明什么？
气候它是一个统计值是算出来的。
比如说来描述气候的。
说我拿我国来举例的话。
北方冬季寒冷干暴。
夏季温和多雨
那么江南地区夏季闷热多雨等等。
这是一种对气候的一个描述。
那么分清楚了
天气和气候的一个差异。
我们可以再来看
就是我们体感上
为什么这种惯天特别多。
这个惯你这个词用的其实特别好。
像我们在区分天气。
类似一种最近的天气比较反常。
我们对它的理解其实也是有两层的一个含义。
第一层叫偏
就是偏离气候值雨下的偏多一点。
气温偏高一点
但它都是一种属于自然的正常波动。
第二层就是您说的这个怪。
它就属于一种极端的异常。
偏大了
就是在历史上的一种小概率事件。
在近些年或者说今年我们能够更多的感受到。
这就是它怪的一个体现。
我这边也有一些数据可以跟大家分享一下。
好啊？
举个例子
像以前的时候我们夏季36摄氏度的高温天气。
可能是只有比如说我们南方的三大火炉。
或者点撞的这种出现。
但是近些年我们能够看到。
比如说华东 华北 西北。
经常大范围的出现这种高温的天气。
而且以前的时候我们北方是很少遭遇这种台风暴雨。
尤其是台风深入内陆的这种情况是很罕见的。
但是近些年台风北上然后深入内陆带来大范围的雨雪。
这种天气也越来越多了。
那么从监测数据上我们看见。
像今年5月13到21号的时候。
今年以来也是历史上5月最强的区域暴雨过程。
就发生在了广东 广西。
我们知道桂港所受到的影响还是比较严重的。
6月20号的时候。
咱们看过新闻就是沙漠地区发达水了。
就是河田地区
它发生了这个罕见的洪水。
它其中有一个小时的降雨量。
是达到了34.3毫米。
3厘米多
对 3厘米多
这个值是接近了当地全年的那个降水量。
就是以往年份的全年。
以往年份全年的降水量。
它一个小时就下了其中的三分之二。
真夸张
这个就是非常极端的一个现象。
那么7月份的时候。
我们也有一个新疆的那个土鲁番爱丁湖景区。
它观察到的日最高气温50.2摄氏度。
这也是成为了新的极端日最高气温。
这个气温还不是地表温度是吧？
是气温
就是咱们用那个专业设备在那个箱里凉出来的那个。
我们知道在火焰山有一个特地表温度的温度计。
大家知道那个是很受关注的。
经常到这个六七十度。
那么刚刚这个数据是大气的那个温度。
爱丁湖的景区
日最高气温是50.20度。
它是超过了这个土鲁番的这个东坎气象站。
原先是48.3摄氏度。
这成为了新的一个日极端最高气温。
这些就是近些年一些极端性的体现。
那么从长期的趋势来看。
中国气象局现在每年都会发布叫中国气候变化蓝皮书。
我们是把1961年以来这个历史的序列。
做了这样的一个演变趋势的一个判断。
我们可以看到不管是极端高温事件的发生评次。
还是极端日降水量的这么一个评次。
它都是呈现增加的那么一个趋势。
同时来讲的话
就是以往的极端事件现在大家感受上是越来越普遍的。
就是越来越怪了
越来越怪
那我插一小问题
为什么1961年的。
1961年咱们才开始有全面的气象检测数据是什么？
1961年的时候咱们中国气象观测站网。
它2400多站
它是数据的质量
然后才更加的靠谱一些。
因为气象标准化的数据格式在世界气象组织。
它是有严格的这样一个界定。
不是说我随便在哪里设个站。
我就可以用它的数据来进行一些科学分析。
像我们现在的国家级的气象观测厂。
它是有标准的这么一个格式。
大小面积周围的观测环境都有严格的这种界定。
明白
所以其实是咱们公布这个数据有的时候。
和大家体感有些差距。
其实是测量方法的问题是吧？
觉得我这热都不行。
脱鞋都占地下了
你那边说35度
我们这么觉得这数不太对。
可能有时候是方法问题是吧？
对
您说的这个是非常对的。
这个就是气象上的一个气氛预报。
和我们的一个体感或者说体感温度的一个差异。
气象上发布的气氛预报的数据。
是在标准百叶箱里面用温度计观测到的一个数据。
它是在我们的观测厂里面。
然后百叶箱它能够足够一些阳光。
它是非常尽可能的去符合大气的一个真实的一个情况。
我们体感的温度除了受真实温度的影响。
还可以受湿度丰富等等一系列的影响。
比如说同样的温度。
在晴天和阴天就是潮湿的时候。
大家这个体感是完全不一样的。
这就是也是社会上经常吐槽气象预报的一个点。
就是说尤其是闷热的时候。
我已经这么难受了。
为什么你们的温度报的还是这么比较低的。
是不是崔老师那边经常得跟大家解释。
科普说我们这个是被大家冤枉的。
是 其实一到夏天的话。
就是很多公众都会质疑说。
你们气象部门不敢报四十字度。
然后因为超四十字度。
还会有这种高物贴等等的这些。
但其实就是气象部门永远是最想说真话的人。
然后我们的这种百叶乡的温度的观测。
这是全球统一的
它是最符合客观的气温的一个数据。
因为它是刚刚我们邵老师也提到了。
就是它是在百叶乡中。
它是有一个遮阴的环境。
大家在实际的工作环境中生活环境中的话。
它有可能是在这种太阳的暴晒下。
体感温度肯定会更高一些。
如果有点风的话
体感也会偏凉一些。
如果湿度大的话
体感又会
因为它会影响这个等排汗。
然后温度的话也会感觉到更高一些。
是
所以是会有这种公众的感知。
跟我们的预报之间有一些这种。
可以说是认知的一些污差。
但其实现在气象预报也在做这种体感温度的预报。
就是大家说
也有这个选项
也有
就是大家看APP上的话也会有。
它可能主要是结合湿度。
去做一些体感温度的一些预测。
也是有的
就是人体舒适度指数。
这样的一个指标
我们的一些APP上都能够看到。
是
那我又有一雕钻的问题了。
既然这个二位老师都说了。
1961年才有这个标准化的。
靠谱的数据
那我们经常在这个极端天气底。
50年1月
100年1月
300年1月
那既然61年才有数据。
这100年1月从何谈起。
首先这个
1961年以来的数据质量。
是比较标准化的
但是我们国的建占从建国开始。
就有全国大进一
将近600多个占的数据。
就49年开始
对
那往更前的话
我们国家也有很多的。
有百年序列的
这么一些气象战
都是根据不同的业务的需要。
大家来选用这个占点的数。
刚刚您提的多少年一遇。
对
我们其实很关心这个。
过去几年
但是晚上也是很火的一个词。
是
就是多少年一遇
它其实是一个概率算出来的。
不是说这50年
就真的没有一次
对
不是说50年就发生过一次。
它是一个概率
就是我历史上发生的次数。
就是说极端强降水的次数。
出于我的相应的时段。
算出来一个概率
那么我再把它折合成。
多少年一遇
就类似这样的
就比如说我有记录是200年。
发生过四次
对
我们现在其实已经不用这样的表述了。
就是为了怕引起这个公众的一种误解。
确实
这方面推老师应该是现有体会。
经常要出来辟
对
最少这么说
但其实从公众的感知来说的话。
确实会感觉到这个天气越来越怪。
就是大家平时看到这种。
经常看到几十年一遇的这种天气。
或者说这种洪水
那你今年出现了
明年又出现了
然后连续好几年都出现了。
那确实是从概率来说的话。
这种极端天气确实是越来越多了。
但可能它并不是说。
真的是这100年只出现过这一次。
那它是一个历史
从历史数据统计的角度来说。
概率的话大概是100年出现一次。
但确实大家只管感受到它越来越怪。
就是因为去年
今年可能都出现了。
确实这怪天一频繁。
这词容易让人误会。
说50年一遇的
我去年遇上了
100年遇
我今年明年再遇200年。
我怎么这么幸运呢？
老让我们感受
其实第一确实是气候越来越怪。
或者说这能叫气候吗？
天气越来越怪了
第二个也是算法的问题。
让我们有一点误解。
二位老师关心的
我反正看起来
今年不光是国内怪。
好像全世界都很怪。
其实前阵子欧洲的高温。
这也是反正媒体报道的话。
都是也是多少年遇遇。
然后我看有一个数据是。
今年欧洲的高温
已经导致2.5万人。
因极端高温丧生
它这个地方
它也是用了一个超额死亡的一个标准。
就是它超出正常死亡率的。
那部分死亡的人数。
就是因为高温导致的。
然后包括大家也看到。
F2铁塔的因为高温。
然后增长了多少高度什么的。
这种新闻也是经常能看到。
然后包括前阵子韩国。
也是经历了历史以来最高的温度。
然后也导致了多少人死亡。
韩国也有历史最高温度。
对
就是全世界国家都在经历。
比较特殊的这种极端的天气。
然后包括南北极
其实南北极的增分速率的话。
是还要比我们像中国这些地区。
它的增分速率会更高一些。
就是南北 南北极。
冰川融化这些
各种的影响都是真实存在的。
就是全球边缆的升温速率。
纬度越高
它的升温速率是越高的。
我们通常这样的理解。
就是越靠近吃到的地方。
它本身的基础温度就高的。
那想可能说吃到的年平均也就有了30度。
而北极年平均请问可能就。
那个零下比如说零下二度。
就举这个例子
那么升温有30度到31度。
它只是升了1度
那有零下二度到零上二度。
那就是升了4度
它那个基础气温偏低的地方。
它的那个升温效果是更明显的。
所以说有两极的海滨 鸡血 融化的。
也都是非常的严重。
那么今年刚刚崔老师也说了。
就是欧洲的这个高温。
我们这周可以看到一个新闻。
就是空调易激难球。
中国知道占领了欧洲的市场。
这个就是受高温最明显的一个影响。
因为欧洲它本身的话。
它的气候类型受北大西洋暖流的一个影响。
它的四季是我们学弟弟都知道。
这从我二十多年没听懂。
它的四季其实是非常温和的。
就是季节的变化不是特别的明显。
所以欧洲的那个其实空调的那个安装率是比较低的。
但是现在受高温的这个影响差点需求就非常的大。
北半球人口密集的地区像中维度。
这个我们传统的这个沙漠地区像中东。
我们也能看到他们发生这种季节性的这种山洪。
像印度的这种高温。
每到这个四五月份的时候。
印度的这个高温的这个影响。
这也是都能够看到这样的一个新闻。
像加拿大
澳大利亚的这个山火。
这些都是受这个高温。
然后干旱这样的一些影响。
南美洲的话
再加上现在这个像俄尔宁洛的一个影响。
亚马逊的这个热带雨林。
他们继续性的干旱都是非常严重的。
那我们刚才听少尔说的时候。
一直有一个前提叫全球变暖。
那我想就以今年为例吧？
咱们全球的这些极端天气里边。
有没有变冷的呢？
有没有比平时冷的。
反正我在北京七月份之前。
我的感觉是呦
今天北京那天怪啊？
今天凉快
今天是一直特别凉快。
一直雨三天一下两天一下。
北京很少有这样的天气。
一直二十多度都甚至还要穿长袖呢？
但是这八月以来直接打脸了。
那是不是地球上大家普遍都是在变暖的。
而不是说这边变暖。
那边极端的比平时凉快。
这个刚刚讲的这个变暖。
它是从一个长期的趋势来看。
它是一个变暖的一个趋势。
这是一个气候上的一个属于。
那么具体到我们每天的天气。
每周的天气
它是存在一个自然的波动。
我们很明显的感受到。
这个七月份的时候。
北京是很舒服的
是
对
这个就是阶段性的这么一个。
就是气温不算很高的一个过程。
它可以理解为就是刚刚说的那个偏。
照常年七月的气温偏凉。
偏冷这样的一种描述。
但还达不到这个极端的这么一个。
特点
而且夏季的时候
夏季的时候就是下半年。
夏季我们国家包括全球。
更多的是一种偏暖的这种趋势。
到冬季的时候
这个冷暖的差异
它就会有更明显的这么一个特点。
我们现在冬季刚讲的时候。
经常的比如说这个冷欧亚。
南北极
有的时候就是冷空气一下来。
北极那边离开温度。
它是偏高的
但是整个欧亚大陆冷空气。
寒潮
频发
就这样的一种特点。
而且还有一个
像北美
北美大陆冷的时候。
欧亚一般是暖的
欧亚大陆冷的时候。
北美一般是暖的
这是冬季
对冬季的时候
这就是全球大气环流。
它是我们用一种波动的一种概念。
来理论来解释
就是此消彼长
首先这第一部分
咱们确实从二位老师嘴里。
确认了
现在这怪天就是越来越多。
那这个怪天
我们又想了一个更长维度的事情。
就是这怪天
在我们这一辈子几十年里。
看确实是越来越多了。
但是如果放眼到历史上。
放眼到整个人类历史维度。
甚至生物维度
地球维度
那么我们现在这个怪天还算怪吗？
还是说其实这是一个很正常的小颤抖。
这个就是涉及到气候变化的尺度。
我们一般对气候变化的研究。
它分为三个尺度
第一个尺度就是地质时期的气候变化。
就是渐冰期的循环。
这个可能是几百万年。
到上一年的这样一个尺度。
主要的技术手段
就是通过像我们的冰芯。
然后这个树木
包括岩层
它的一种同位素的变化。
去估算出当时那个时期的变化。
这样取冰芯或者在岩层里取。
这样能够得出来的数据。
发现在地质时期的话。
存在比现在这个温度更高的这个时期。
也有温度比现在低的这个时期。
就是冰期与渐冰期的这么一个循环。
像我们圣物上提到的这个韩五季生命大爆发。
包括这个恐龙时代。
这都是相对温暖的这么一个时期。
我们从
生物大爆发的时期往往温暖。
对
然后像恐龙存在的时候。
它首先一些比如说。
这个只吃植物的这些动物。
它首先要有土固的食物。
据说当时的时候
南极甚至都有森林的这种存在。
这些都是地质时期的气候变化。
那么第二个就是
人类历史时期的一个气候变化。
它主要是指人类或者说有这个人类文明以来。
这样的一个变化
这个咱们国家
就是朱可珍先生
他有一条非常著名的曲线。
叫朱可珍曲线
我刚刚在楼下看到朱可珍先生给咱们提的。
《求是精神》那个词。
对 我们一路一路想起来了。
朱可珍先生有提词。
这个朱可珍曲线就是朱可珍先生。
他根据考古记录
然后我们的史籍记载。
包括一些地方制
还有巫侯观特
他从这些古籍里面去筛选气候变化的信息。
就把过去五千年中国的气温。
做了这样一个分区。
中间也有一些冷暖的一些变化。
像我们比较知道的养烧。
养烧文化时候是一个暖期。
我们的这个商周
然后隋唐是一个暖期。
那么近的就是像明清是一个小兵期。
就类似于这样的一个序列。
这就是历史时期的一个气候变化。
我们能够从这些古籍中得到。
而且朱可珍先生通过古籍中。
他得到了这个结论。
跟后来大家就是科学家从北极。
格林兰群岛的这个兵心里面得到的序列。
非常的一致
也是体现了这项工作的这个。
重要意义和它的一个重要性。
同时也反映了咱们国家这个文明史。
它的也是连续未中断。
这样一个很准确的一个特点。
那么第三个尺度
就是工业革命以来。
近百年有了科学的仪器观测。
这样一个尺度
我们现在所讲的全球变暖。
一般就是指这工业革命以来。
由于人类活动的一个影响。
所造成的这个全球变暖。
在历史上是存在过。
就是不管是地质时期还是历史时期。
存在过这个冷暖交替的这么一个情况。
像历史时期的话
在古代它的一个转换的一个。
冷暖转换的一个尺度。
可能得是几百年
几十年到几百年的这么一个区间。
是非常缓慢的一种自然变化。
从来没有出现过
像现在过去几十年。
温度如此快速的这么一个上升。
是没有出现过类似于这样的一个情况。
它就是在非常短的时间内。
温度上升得特别快。
这个就要归依于人类活动的对它造成的一个影响。
明白
我们如果把现在
就是最近几十年的温度的监测。
叠加到竹核中山上的曲线上的话。
你会非常明显能看到。
工业革命以来温度是斗增的。
就是从气候变律的角度。
它是几万年 几百万年。
它会经历这种兵器 舰兵器。
它是有一个自然变律的。
但是工业革命以来。
在人类影响下的增温是非常明显的。
是前所未有的
然后也有一些国家或者说有一些政客。
他就是说气候变暖是一个谎言。
说但其实气候变暖是真实存在的。
而且是全世界的科学家的一个共识。
这是绝对毋庸置疑的。
但是可能会有些国家有些政客。
他为了这种能源的发展。
或者经济的发展
他说气候变化是谎言。
然后为了去有一些这种利益方面的糾纲。
但从科学事实来讲的话。
气候变暖是毋庸置疑的。
而且人类活动的影响。
对于气候变暖的这种贡献度是非常大的。
我这边也有一个数据。
就是IPCC就是政府兼气候变化。
专门委员会的一个数据。
这是个国际组织吗？
对
明白
它记录到2016年到2025年。
这10年的平均的全球升温。
相对于1850到1900年平均温度。
升温达到了1.26摄氏度。
其中人类贡献是1.24摄氏度。
也就是说如果没有人类活动的话。
我们通过这种骨气候。
然后从那种
就是包括朱克人先上那个曲线来看的话。
它相对于1850到1900年。
它应该是上升0.020摄氏度。
但是因为有这些人类贡献度。
它升了1.26摄氏度。
这面前还是非常区别。
那是很大张
那是不是等于说我们截止到目前为止。
从这个争气机发明到现在。
这段时间的这个增热。
实际上已经比历史上的热气要更热了。
这个没有准确数据是吧？
跟历史上就地质时期最暖的时候。
还没有达到
不 咱不提地质时期。
就是有人有人一来。
比如说我们是觉得。
唐朝还是什么时候是个偏热的时期。
会比那个时期更热吗？
像仰潮文化和唐朝的时期。
气温比现在要高的。
比现在还要高
等于那会还是比现在更热的。
那其实大家还不用这么担心。
好像还没有说完这种灭顶之灾。
很欢迎
现在担心的是
如此短的时间内
温度升高了这么多。
就是这个升温速率。
历史上是从来没有过的。
这是我们现在最担心的。
这个可能会造成什么影响。
因为我们知道
多一度多两度
这是有死数的
它能够带来多少的碳的变化。
生物的变化
那这个协律变化能导致什么问题呢？
如果是一种自然的波动。
不管是缓慢的升温还是缓慢的降温。
大自然有适应的一个过程。
但是现在如此快的这么一个增温过程。
我们的自然
包括经济社会
没法快速的去适应这样一个变化。
我们有一个叫气候临界点。
是选了十三个类
比如说像这个热带的这个山湖白化。
我们的这个海平面上升。
我们这个疾病融化。
对于这个温延环流了一些影响。
就是气候临界点
就是如果说如此快速升温的这么一个状态。
打破了这个气候临界点以后。
就类似于发生了气候突变一样。
它进入一种不可逆的状态。
那对我们这个经济社会。
自然循环的这么一个影响。
它是一个耽耐性的影响。
像现在我们这个地球上。
这个保持极地和热带平衡的。
有一个叫温延环流。
温延环流
对温延环流
那俩是温带
温度
气温的温
延度的延
就是吃的延的那个延。
温延环流
它就是从这个极地到高纬度。
这样一个非常缓慢的一个循环。
现在全球变暖
那导致这个极地升温高之后。
北极地区大量的海滨融化之后。
那个进入这个海水里面。
就对这个温延环流的循环。
就产生了一些影响。
温延环流的循环
它靠的是一个梯度。
就是高尾地区和地尾地区的。
延度的差异温度的差异。
大量的这个海滨融化进入海洋之后。
延度稀释了
就是延度的差异变小了。
同时升温之后温度的梯度也变小了。
现在这个温延环流。
它就有崩溃的这么一个风险。
而且它不还了
对
它一不还之后
整个的极地到高尾的热量的。
这么一个疏送循环。
它就会打破
其实有一个非常直观的一个例子。
也是前两天咱们中国国家地理杂志上发的一个。
现在世界四大渔厂变成了三大渔厂。
就是那个
加拿大东部的那个渔厂。
因为它已经叫官门歇业了。
它又很大一部分
就是受这个环流异常的这么一个影响。
不适合于类的这个生存了。
这是其中的一个方面。
再一个的话
像现在全球面团导致的海平面的上升。
对太平洋的一些岛国。
包括东南亚的一些国家。
都产生了非常明显的一些影响。
像类对印尼的这个迁都。
它都是受这方面影响的一种体现。
是变化太大了
措手无极
就是连公条都来不及适应。
对来不及造空调的。
而且是打破了一接点之后。
它是不可逆的
明白
这种变化就是非常的快。
就是大自然它本身它是能够。
从千百年来看大自然的话。
它是在适用气候的一个变化的。
但是在这么快的一个变温速率下。
它会来不及适应
就像我们山地的话。
这种植贝的覆盖的话。
它是从这个地海拔地区到高海拔的话。
它是有一个梯度的。
然后这些植物的话。
它没有办法说在几年内。
然后因为这个雪线上升。
然后它就迁移到更高的地方去。
然后这些动物的话。
它感觉到这个温度变化。
它会迁移
它迁移之后
它这些植物什么的没有变化。
它就会有一个错位。
吃着东西
对
就会导致生态的一个稳乱。
现在有很多这种气候模型。
去预测如果说变暖的速率。
继续维持下去的话。
可能到我们有生之年的话。
有可能会看到更多的导国。
就会被淹没了
然后会有更多的这种气候变化。
带来的一些灾难
是我们有生之年有可能会看到的。
但是如果是在自然的变率下的话。
缓慢的变化下的话。
这些是我们很难会遇到的。
一些极端的天气
毁灭性的这种灾难。
是有生之年是看不到的。
但其实如果这样持续升温下去的话。
这些模型都已经预测到了。
就是我们气象和气候的话。
它是一门预测科学。
我们在说天气变得越来越怪。
确实我们直观的感受是在越来越怪。
对比这种几百年前的气候变化的话。
确实越来越怪
但其实对于气象和气候学家来说。
这些都是在近几十年来。
是已经预测到了
就是根据我们检测到了。
这种气候变暖的这种速率。
去推测出来的
除了人为的因素以外。
我们还知道有很多自然的因素。
确实会导致全球温度的不断的变化。
不管是周期性的变化。
还是往热热的变化。
比如说我们杂志上期的主题。
包括大家现在常说的这个二尼诺。
蓝尼达这组词
大家老听而书能详。
二位老师咱们用简单的语言。
给它解释解释
啥是真正的二尼诺。
它到底是怎么影响我们的天气的呢？
二尼诺和它有一个兄弟叫拉尼诺。
这两个它是指的一个海洋异常的一个现象。
就是赤道中东太平洋的海温异常偏高。
就是二尼诺异常偏低。
就是拉尼诺
而这是通俗的一些理解。
那么至于它的强度。
它有一个严格的国家标准。
它是怎么形成的呢？
就是根据大气环流。
在赤道地区太平洋正常的年份。
它是自东往西来吹信封。
信封就会把赤道中东太平洋的海温海水往西边吹。
就导致一般的西太平洋的海温温度是偏高的。
我们一般把它叫做西太暖池。
那么每个几年信封就会减弱。
信封一减弱之后
西边的这个海水暖水就开始回流。
这个时候吃到中东太平洋的海温就会慢慢的上升。
这个就会出现这个二尼诺的一个现象。
那么信封增强的时候。
那会把更多的海水吹到西边。
那东边的海水就是由底部的海水来补偿。
它的温度会更低
这就是拉尼诺的一个现象。
这都是大气环流
就是会隔一段时间就会出现了一种循环的一个现象。
那么二尼诺出现之后。
它的一个影响是全球范围的一个影响。
像对澳大利亚
然后包括南美都有非常险重的影响。
那么针对我国的话。
我们传统上来讲的话。
一般二尼诺年的时候。
它会导致我们夏季的雨带是南方多雨。
而北方少雨
那么冬季的时候温度会一般是偏高的。
就从统计上来讲
但是这些年加上全球变暖的影响。
以及二尼诺它的不同的发展阶段。
它的影响也是变得越来的越复杂。
现在就不能一概而论这个变化。
对 这就回到对处你的那个怪。
很多以前的规律性的东西被打破了。
这也对我们预测科学来说一个非常大的一个挑战。
就是像二尼诺年的这种二尼诺年。
从概率统计来说北方应该是少雨的。
但是今年明显的北方东北花北都是降雨片多。
是
刚才您提到了一个。
有一个一般年
然后有二尼诺年拉尼那年。
这太难念了
那也就是说在历史上。
其实这两种现象不是一定会交替出现的。
一有的年就是没有。
还是说其实就是会有几年。
二尼诺有几年
拉尼诺自古就是这样。
不严格的交替出现。
有的时候可能连续两到三年都是二尼诺年。
回来两到三年都是拉尼诺一样。
但是它是一个自然的波动。
它是会周期性的这种出现。
这个是肯定的
就是存在既不而你说又不拉尼诺的年份。
那就是正常的年份。
就是正常年份
所以正常年份还是占了大部分。
大部分
明白
那有没有统计说
比如说随着年代越来越靠后。
无异般的年份比例越来越高。
现在有这个趋势
就是二尼诺和拉尼诺的疲惫越来越高。
这个数据我这边目前还不掌握。
有没有这样的研究还不太清楚。
但是你从历史上来看的话。
比如像98年16年。
这都是非常典型的二尼诺年。
像08年我们全国的冬季的鱼血病毒灾害。
那当时就是拉尼诺的一个大的背景。
具体的概率增议有没有增加。
手边没有数据
不敢下定乱
但是我们能确定的就是。
二尼诺年和拉尼诺年出现的时候。
它对气候异常的影响。
这个是比较显著的。
而且从最近这些年来看的话。
也是拉尼诺和二尼诺年。
我直观感受
最近10年的话是频率比较高一些。
就体感确实是多了。
像三重拉尼诺
就连续三年拉尼诺年。
这种情况在历史上也是没有那么常见的。
然后现在一有个极端天气。
包括我大舅
他都知道拉尼诺而尼诺。
他就问这是不是又是尼诺影响的。
又下暴雨了
然后他现在也特别地关注气候。
关注天气
我觉得可能对于公众来说的话。
因为拉尼诺
大家也更多的去了解天气气候。
去了解去看天气预报与景。
对于大家的生活的指示。
还是有一定的帮助作用。
有一些这种科普的作用。
是
那二尼诺确实是全球外天气的主因吗？
也不能这么说吧？
他只能说是主因之一。
因为影响咱们中国气候的因素。
是非常复杂的
我们一般用东西南北中。
哦
这样来说
应该拆解
东边我们一般指的海洋上。
这个二尼诺
海洋上那个
不管是二尼诺还是拉尼诺。
它通过跟西太富高的这么一个联动。
这是东边的
那么西边
这就是第三级清藏高原。
清藏高原它的一个热力作用。
然后高原风机
这您给我们加个注解了。
我们小白就听不懂了。
高原风机是怎么个意思。
就是清藏高原它在夏季的时候。
因为它是一个非常大的一个热源。
就是离太阳近
太阳的直射它的升温比较快。
然后气流上升
会形成一个低压
这样它就会抽吸周边的空气。
来弥补它上升之后留下的这个。
这就是一个高原的风机的这么一个称呼。
它会对我们中部东部地区造成什么影响呢？
它的影响还是非常显著的。
假如没有清藏高原的话。
整个的像我们的中维都地区。
就是北维三十多那个上下。
就会成为一个沙漠。
因为根据大气环流的话。
在中维度是一个下沉气流。
有负担在高压控制。
就形成类似于像中东一样的沙漠。
但是由于清藏高原大地形的一个存在。
它就改变了原来的一个气候格局。
它加强了影响我们国家的寄风。
那我们的江南的玉米之巷就这样形成了。
明白
就是清藏高原对于江南地区的降水的。
贡献度还是非常大的。
就是现在因为夏季的话。
它是这个夏季风是从孟加拉曼那边上来。
上来出因为高原的阻挡作用。
然后它就伸着可能横断深麦这块。
然后就往南方地区的降水。
是会受到清藏高原的影响是比较大的。
就是等于说夏天的南方降水。
很多是从印度洋这边过来的地方。
是的
西南季风过来
能不能影响到这么远呢？
而不是由东边
不是直接东边上
台风降水更多的是从太平洋卷上来的这种水气。
当然你像前面那个今年广西恒州那个墙降水。
其实那个台风并没有特别的强。
它一方面是这个台风本体的水气带上来。
然后同时跟这个西南季风有一个结合。
然后这两个系统叠加。
然后造成了广西当时降水是非常强。
那个台风其实并没有特别强。
但是降水会非常强。
然后也导致了比较大的一个灾害。
那这是您说的东和西。
南北东呢？
对南边的话就是刚刚说的印度洋还有南海。
它的一个海温
然后水气这样的一个影响。
然后北边我们一般就是指中高委的冷空气活动。
包括北极海滨对我们国家的一个影响。
北极海滨都能对咱造成影响。
对
因为由东到下我们讲究季节进程。
季节进程的话
它就是受不同的这么因素的一个主导作用。
像下半年的时候我们就是看。
像拿这个雨季进程来举个例子。
我们传统成了比如说。
每年的5月份是这个华南前训期。
华南前训期
对
就这个时候雨带是在华南地区。
那么6月份6月中旬到7月上旬的时候。
雨带是在长江流域。
我们把它叫做梅雨季。
那么到了七下八上。
就是防汛关键期的时候。
雨带一般的会北推到华北东北。
就北方地区
也就是我们当下经历的时段。
都把它叫做北方的一个防汛关键期。
这样的一个季节进程。
它就是不同的大气环流的因素。
相互作用的一个结果。
等于说还是很复杂。
就是厄里诺其实
起码对于咱们国家来说。
只是几个因素之一。
对 影响因素之一。
但是有的时候它的作用会非常大。
因为它既有直接影响。
也有间接影响
它直接的影响就是。
对沃克环流
就是海洋上的环流。
产生了影响
那么同时它也会对它的下游。
而尼诺对大西洋产生影响。
那么就会导致全球的大气环流。
不同的区域都会出现。
相应的这种调整
明白
就是气候预测这块话。
大家还是要以国家气候中心这边为准。
就是因为为什么这么说。
就是一到冬天
然后有很多自媒体。
或者有些公众会判断。
就是根据拉尼娜年。
肯定是一个冷冬
然后20年代年有暖冬。
就是会有一些这种判断。
但其实它冬季气候预测。
夏季气候预测
它是要结合很多气候因素的。
就像少老师说的
像北极海滨等等的。
拉尼娜20年代
只是其中的一个因素。
气候中心会结合这个因素。
去进行综合的研判。
所以大家还是以官方的气候预测为准。
国家气候中心的气候预测。
尤其是迅期的气候预测。
和冬季的气候预测。
我们都叫做全国大会商。
全国大会商
对
像迅期就是夏季六七八三个月的预测。
是每年三月份的时候。
中国气候局国家气候中心。
就是邀请气象系统。
然后相关的高校科研院院所。
所有的专家齐聚一堂。
共同的来商定
迅期的这么一个气候趋势的一个结论。
然后最终再形成这样一个。
这其实是一个重置。
是一个极思广义的这么一个过程。
同样冬季的预测也是这样的一个。
每年的十月下雪
十月底我们会组织。
也是全国专家
然后进行商讨
最终来拟定这样的一个意见。
那么后续根据气候形式的一个演变。
进行修订或者说调整。
对
这我就得问一外行问题了。
因为数据都是咱们国家气象中心。
气象局拿到的这些数据。
权威数据
数据就摆在这
那这个预测为什么不同的专家。
不同的单位
还会有不同的预测。
大家还得商量的
而不是根据这些数据就有一个统一的。
它这个数据这么走了。
那肯定就要那么变。
还不是这样的吗？
这个就从我刚刚跟您说的。
比如说影响中国的。
我们把它叫东西南北中。
都有不同的影响因素。
它中间有非常复杂的这么一个物理机制。
不同的专家
它的研究的角度是不一样的。
这个时候就是有的。
比如说我特种于从海滨对气候的影响。
来做预测
比如说我用海温的影响。
比如说我从青藏高原的角度。
这个时候其实大家的预测会有差异。
因为我不知道明年到底哪一个起主导作用。
这个是很难判断的起主导作用的。
所以会商就是这样。
把大家的意见都综合在一起。
每个角度都有各自的道理。
那谁能拍这个版说。
哪个角度最科学
哪个角度会最主要的。
就是崔老师悄悄的指了少老师一下。
这个就是根据会商意见之后。
这个是由专家来调定的。
就是会有专门的
比如说少老师这样的专家来。
综合各方意见
但是会给一个权重。
会综合得到这么一个意见。
这个就是后期你再看这个。
这句话我不知道合不合适。
就是不管是天气预报还是气候预测。
我们都是首席负责者。
这个没问题
对
这个确实
对综合首席来确定的意见。
形成相应的预测报告。
这个报告领导那领导是不会改的。
这个确实国家气象中心。
那肯定就是权威的拍板机构了。
但是这个拍板是怎么个拍法。
就是确实听您刚才这么说。
当然我是小白了
就是各位专家的角度不同。
那角度不同就都有道理。
各有道理
这怎么去判断明年是喜马拉雅的影响最大呢？
还是海上的影响最大呢？
因为它综合的这个意见之后。
它有一定的一致性。
一致的地方基本上就不聊了。
聊的是什么？
聊的是差异的地方。
差异的地方这个时候。
这就是会商的一个重点。
我们想听听这专家是怎么打架的。
听什么你那因素就比我的因素影响全中高。
因为你要把自己的预测依据。
我们讲预测依据
你要把自己的预测依据说清楚。
我为什么根据这个。
这个就是涉及到专家的一些多年的这种科研成果。
它已经就深耕领域时间比较长。
它对一些经验性的里面一些几里。
包括近些年AI模型的一些应用。
它是有这个自信的。
它把它的道理讲清楚了。
然后最后意见的时候会采纳。
如果说这个说的那么不是特别的理由。
不是特别的充分
可能会进行这个就是大家做情的考虑一下。
明白
等于这种预测
虽然大家的数据理由都是科学的。
但是其实判断很多还是要靠人为来判断的。
是吧？
根据科学的这么一些科学的结论。
然后再进行这个预报员。
他经验的一个判定。
当然我们不否认的是存在不确定性。
不管是天气预报还是气候预测。
它有非常大的不确定性。
本身大气它就是混沌的一种。
所以这个的话就是后期要进行不断的。
每个滚动的一些盯证。
就预测结论进行一个微调这样的一个。
那是不是总体上来说。
随着科学和我们的经验的变多。
我们现在预测的准确度确实是越来越高了。
是越来越高的
从天气预报的角度的话。
就是大家共同看到的。
就是三天以内的预报基本上是比较准确的。
七天的话就是给大家可以看一个。
这个降水的趋势
然后可能温度上升的一个趋势。
这种大概率也不会有错。
然后气候预测的话。
它可能也是更宏观的角度去判断。
这个季节会不会偏暖偏冷。
现在气候部门也在提这个低净式服务。
就是对于一次天气过程。
或者一次这种大的气候过程的话。
大家会有一个超长期的预判。
预判之后这个范围可能会比较大一些。
然后可能净度没有那么精确。
但是我们会一直去跟踪这个过程。
然后七天三天
逐步的去把这个预报净度就会更加细一些。
大家对于这次过程的把握也会更加准确一些。
就可能七天的时候。
大家知道会有一个大的天气过程过来。
会有一些体验的准备。
然后越到临近的时候。
大家的准备就会更加的有针对性。
这样对于防灾减灾的话也会更加有帮助。
像这个提到气候预测的话。
最后归口应该还是国家气候中心。
就是大家会满了之后。
是由国家气候中心来发布出来这个气候预测。
其实气候部门的话有两个比较大的。
比较有名的汇商系统。
就是一个是气候预测这个系统。
还有一个就是天气汇商系统。
这个的话就是每天早上的话。
就是您提到的有国家气象中心。
来牵头这个天气
每天的天气
还有国家气象中心。
对
还有国家气候中心。
从明天到明天
国家也能看到气候的话就变成偏长期。
对
我们是在业务上的一个区别。
国家气象中心
它有一个更响亮的名字。
就是中央气象台
它做的就是
这是一个单位两块牌子。
对
它做的就是两周以内。
十四天以内的天气预报。
然后十四天以上的四季节到季节。
到这个月
年来至百年的气候变化的预估。
就都是我们国家气候中心的一个业务。
明白了
这还这么分成两块。
对
一般人还真不知道这个。
就是把天气气候的预测给衔接起来了。
两个部门相当于
每天的天气会商
其实也是就是中央气象台牵头。
然后各地的省级的预报员。
来参加全国的
可能第四级的
也都关注这个会商。
每天早上都会去看会商。
包括我们像我们宣传科普的。
我们每天也会去看这个会商。
会商是每天会商
每天会商
天气会商是每天
对
每天都会商
每天早上8点
对
这些专家也够累的。
如果像这种有台风。
有这种重大的天气过程的话。
下午4点还会有一次加密会商。
哦
就会把这个受影响要严重的省份。
然后首席预报员也拉出来。
然后大家一起会商一下。
这个天气的影响
因为可能从中央象台。
预报员的角度
他可能对于整个全国的天气。
更掌握一些他的理论。
也可能会更扎实一些。
但是对于地方的
首席预报员来说
他对于当地的情况。
地形等等这些因素。
会更了解一些
然后中央象台的专家。
跟这个地方的首席预报员。
也会进行一个会商。
他现在的天气预报和气候预测的话。
他也会有很多这种气候模型。
天气模型
然后大家基于
包括欧洲的美国的也会去看。
然后中央象台
包括气候中心也有自己的模型。
然后有计算机
超级计算机
综合这些气象因素。
气象数据
然后地形数据等等的。
算出来一个天气预报的结果。
气候预测的一个结果。
然后这些气象预报员。
他们有
就是当地的有一些。
会有一些更有经验的一些部分。
就是对地形的
对降水的一个增幅。
然后包括对于过去的。
相似的这种气象条件下。
然后当时是怎么样一个降水情况。
然后结合自己的一些经验。
对计算机算出来的这个预报结果。
进行一些盯证
因为咱们今天的主题是。
这个天气越来越怪。
其实从预报员的角度来看。
也是天气时代越来越怪了。
就是我印象表深的是。
当时北京有一年
北京有一年夏季降水。
就是破丽时即时的那次。
7月13
对
7月23
7月23号
那次就是中央气象台的。
好几个首席预报员坐在一起。
然后包括北京市气象台的。
首席预报员坐在一起。
大家会上这次降水的过程。
当时首席预报员
就是判断那次降水。
就预报模式的话
应该是判断是超过600毫米。
大概是600毫米。
大概这样一个数字。
然后首席预报员说。
这个
因为之前从来没有预报过。
那么大的降水
那次确实我印象都很深。
对
预报员的话就是觉得。
可能比模式报道还会更大一些。
这个决定是很难下的。
因为过去从来没有过。
预报模式从来没有过。
然后预报员也从来没有经历过。
第一责任人
说的话得负责任
当时的降水量应该是800还是1000。
我第一次
临时也是唯一一次。
在北京的大马路上。
在大马路上水淹到我嘴里了。
那次
就当然有马路击水的问题。
当时你就想
就是那么多首席预报员在一起。
都从来没有经历过的。
所以大家要一起在一起研判。
那次给我的
就印象也非常深刻。
非常震撼的是
首席预报员在那拍板说。
这个可能比手都要多。
还要多
我们还是真是
可能大家也从来不知道。
您在一客户节目里。
可能也第一次听到。
原来这种气象的天气的。
最终给我们的这个判断。
是有很多真人在那。
博弈和会商出来的结果。
那也向这些老师们致敬。
我们原来手机上每一个。
下一小时的天气
都是大家商量出来的。
大家去讨论出来的。
这些人手续告远好多。
因为他有一次过
就是没有这种
每次这种重大的天气过程的时候。
大家都会紧张着这个过程。
然后不断的去看
这项数据
不断的去研判
然后还会直接扳什么的。
头发白的真的是挺快的。
能不能听
听的就肯定挺不容易。
但是压力应该也挺大的。
有责任
而且它是一种计时的演叶。
我报明天的天气
明天就知道了
到底报的准备
对
这个是压力非常大的。
那咱们
刚才其实少尔已经提到这个问题。
就是沧海桑田变化。
这个这也是我们现在很关心的。
一个问题
我们经常能看到这个。
反正报道上说
这个哪的沙漠
又变成这个绿洲了。
哪的这个原来是水的地方。
现在都被大陆填满了。
我们经常能看到这样的预报。
反正我们杂志上
大家也可以看内华达州。
这是我们杂志上提到的内华达州。
原来几乎寸草不生的这个死亡股。
荒漠
现在也变成花海了。
那就问问二位老师。
历史上像这种沧海桑田的变化。
是不是其实在气象气候维度上。
也是一个很正常的事情。
那么我们随着怪天气越来越多。
我们真的会在我们有生之连。
就看到这种沧海桑田的变化。
还是说他就是
今年热扎一蒙子
明天要回来了
这个就是一个
短期波动还是长期趋势。
是这样的一个问题。
这次是专业
因为在历史上肯定是有过。
随着温度和降水的一个变化。
整体的气候格局
进行一个大的这么一些调整。
这些是肯定历史上是存在的。
像我们回到刚刚说的汉堂的时候。
汉堂的时候我们遭到这个河西走廊。
河西走廊现在
现在是以这个就是肝汗区。
肝汗少雨
但在汉堂的时候
我们知道这个像河西四郡。
朝野九泉
那个时候不只能屯兵还能屯田。
这就是当时受当时的温度和降水的一个条件。
所决定的
那么现在近些年我们看到的一些新闻的报道。
可能说沙漠变绿洲。
尤其是像咱们国内对明显的。
就是一个咱们那个叫是魔物宿。
魔物宿沙地好像要消失了。
就是通过这个它有自然的一些原因。
也有人为的一些因素。
那么人为的因素
就是咱们国家现在这个三北工程建设。
包括这个美丽中国建设。
进行这个像草庞阁。
然后指数造林这样的一系列的一些举措。
它的一个技术条件就是自然条件的一个改善。
我们现在主要看这个干旱区的400毫米的等降雨量线。
对这个线是由往西北移动的这么一个趋势。
那么随着这样的一个趋势的话。
每年这种季节性的。
当这个降水增多的时候。
可能就会出现这种沙漠变绿的这么一个趋势。
像我们新闻今年这个张叶的七彩丹霞。
变成抹茶丹霞
那就是在原来的丹霞上长好了。
是吧？
意识不知道高兴
对不高兴
对就类似一段的趋势。
但它会不会稳定下来。
刚刚崔老师也讲了。
就是说温度
然后降水一年的一个变化。
动物可能反映了
但是植物植被的生长范围。
它没有那么快
所以这个还要看长期。
未来的这么一个具体的趋势。
崔老师呢？
就是咱们国家这些年植树造林。
退根还草这些城就是有目共睹的。
这也建立在一个前提下。
就是是在七侯世仪的情况下。
降水是足够
然后再加上合理的管理。
是能够让沙漠变绿洲的。
但是沙漠这个东西。
它地球上不会消失的。
它有它的一个生态价值。
它在有些沙漠如果这个降水。
不够的话
强行去种植这种绿色植被的话。
它也是不能够持久下去。
而且可能越来越坏。
我们之前专门聊过一起沙漠。
是的
所以沙漠它不会消失。
然后大家可能在我们国家。
在合理的管理下的话。
确实能够看到沙漠会变绿。
会越来越多
这种是在我们这种合理的管理下。
然后也是在这种降水。
足够的情况下是会出现的。
然后现在包括农业的话。
也有一些变化
就是种植带
种在北夷
因为这种气温全球变暖。
气温在升高
然后有些地方
可能之前没法种玉米的。
现在就可以种植了。
我过去我在内蒙古五川县。
当时它是一个叫农墓交错带。
它就是在400毫米等降水县的。
左右分布的这样一个情况。
然后也就是说400毫米的。
降水量达不到的话。
它更适合去放牧
然后达到400米以上的话。
大家就可以来种地。
然后降水量足够
那现在它也是在
逐渐的一个北夷的一个过程。
一方面是让这个种植带扩大了。
就是我们可以
这个种植的粮食更多了。
但其实它也会带了一些风险。
国家气温中心
中央抢局的话
也现在也在做一个事情。
就是叫农业气候区化。
普查和区化
就是要研究气候变化下。
降水量温度分配的一个情况。
然后对于这些农做物。
到底应该种植在北夷。
北夷到哪些地方
做一个具体的一个划分。
然后这样更加的
好 直到大家去做种植等等。
明白
那我问一下丧的问题。
既然它北夷了
这个原来种不了的地儿它能种吗？
那原来很好种的地儿。
像我们知道
这个东南江热地区。
可能历史上是泽国。
可能是美日期害时期。
就也不太好种地
都是流放的大豆香喜意的。
都是干这个的地方。
那会不会随着天气的变化。
气候的变化
我们原来这些鱼米之香。
倒反而不能种
或者是原来很好的。
现在不是医生产了。
这种情况现在有
或者是有可见的未来。
能看到吗？
它可能倒不是说
这个地方不再是一种了。
但是就是这种灾害的风险。
是需要更加去
就包括咱们这个农业。
求资源补查和区化的话。
它也在去分析这些。
这个气候灾害的情况。
包括像河南的话
就是小麦种植非常重要。
但是我们看过去这些年的话。
像干汗的情况也遇到我。
然后烂肠鱼也遇到我。
干热风也遇到我
每年的话
都会有一些比较极端的一些气象灾害。
这个是过去非常适合种植的。
这些地区的话
需要更加整体的
就是这种极端天气的这种防范。
明白
灾害可能会比原来更频繁。
是
除了一些极端性的天气。
尤其是它气候变化。
带来一些生态影响的变化。
比如说我们的病冲害等等。
也会对农业生产产成影响。
但是现在跟古代最大的不同是什么呢？
比如在农业社会的时候。
它是纯粹的靠天吃饭。
可能说天气年纪不好的时候。
就会导致颗粒无收。
是
但是现在我们最大的一个。
就是我们现在的科技实力。
在农业服务方面
像我们气象部门的话。
有专门的农业气象服务。
这样一个业务
对它的一个全生长周期。
进行一个监测相应的。
这么一个气象灾害的预报。
同时现在我们对农业灾害的防御能力。
已经大大的提升了。
这对这样的灾害
它造成了一些影响。
可能比以前要小很多了。
不会明显的影响粮食的产量。
这也是现在为什么？
我们要更多的去做气象研究。
气候研究
然后这样就是做了这些研究之后。
你才能更好地去指导能力生产。
像今年春天的话
我去过一次河南的新乡。
去年的话
他们是经历了秋季的时候联姻雨。
当时秋波是这个波重。
去年的波重是明显晚了。
大概20天左右
这样就导致今年春天的时候。
它那个苗是偏小的。
就肯定会偏小的
偏分孽数也不足
然后这样是对于农业生产的影响。
是很大的
我们提前预判到了。
这个联姻雨的情况。
然后晚波的情况
然后对于春季的一个降水。
通过气象预报
气候预测
然后也选择在一个。
比较合适的一个窗口期。
对于这些小麦
是肥
然后增加灌溉
然后让它能长得更快一些。
能够把之前晚的这20天。
这个进度也赶上
那对于农业生产的影响就没有那么大了。
就是一方面灾害确实越来越多。
越来越极端
然后我们通过去研究这些气象灾害什么的。
然后包括更加精准的去做好。
这种气象预报
气象预测
然后去指导农业生产。
就能够很大程度上去减少这些灾害的影响。
好
听了二位老师说
确实现在随着我们气候。
天气科学的发展
包括两位老师等等。
科学家人的努力
我们预测越来越准了。
能给大家指导生活生产越来越精细。
那我们作为老百姓的。
我最后一个问题
就是我们作为老百姓。
我们现在一知
我们现在的气象天气的预测已经这么好了。
但是怪天也越来越多了。
我们怎么能利用好二位老师当。
给我们提供的这些信息。
来指导我们的生活。
以及在未来可能的连续的这种怪天。
越来越多的情况下。
我们怎么应对
二位从专家的角度上跟我们说。
我们这老百姓得怎么应对这些怪天气。
其实现在大家生活也越来越好。
科技也越来越发达了。
但是一定要老记一件事情。
要敬畏自然
你看疫情之后
大家越来越多的去到户外。
最喜欢去露营
然后家家户户都有车。
也喜欢把车开到这种像河滩地带。
山区地带
但是大家记得就是夏天避暑的时候。
夏天又是一个讯期。
讯期是全年之中
天气灾害最多的一个时候。
就很容易发生这种。
山红泥石油等等灾害。
大家为了这种享受意识的这种舒服。
然后又觉得科技很发达。
然后救援什么的都很发达。
应该不会有事吧？
但其实往往这种时候。
是这种山红泥石油灾害多发的时候。
是很容易出现这种风险的。
所以大家现在出门。
可能也对于天气预报的关注度。
其实也在增加了
你想我要带
因为我有孩子
然后主要是亲子游。
然后我会特别关注天气。
就会有冯家期的话。
我会看看这个地区天气怎么样。
然后那个地区天气怎么样。
然后去选择去哪儿去旅游。
现在天气预报可以说是越来越准了。
就是你对于七天的一个天气趋势的判断。
是比较准确的
然后三天的话是比较准。
更准一些
然后气象预警
它是有短连预报
就24小时之内的。
或者是48小时之内的一个。
对于灾害的预警
它会更准确一些
大家不要去忽视这种预警信息。
不要觉得说科技很发达。
然后又有车
怎么躲在车里出人安全等等的。
其实不是这样的
一定要尽为自然
要留意这种灾害性天气。
看我们的预报预警信息。
明白
小心为上
邵老师呢？
我是觉得现在的全球变暖的。
那么一个大的背景下。
我们如何更好地去生活工作。
然后这样的话
我觉得从一个是对咱们日常生活。
日常生活
像咱们中国人向来讲。
就是顺应天时
我们气候上就有一个24节气。
这样一个韵律性的一个。
它结合我们的生活。
养生都有一系列的这种。
我觉得这是对我们日常生活。
有一个非常好的一个贪好。
就是不要别扭着节气去过日子。
一定要顺应
对
这个称呼秋冬等等。
类似于这样的
这是对我们日常的生活。
那第二个就是您刚说的这种怪天。
它现在
一个是可能说是变多了。
第二个有的时候它是促不及防的。
这就是刚刚邵老师给的那个建议。
一定要敬畏自然
我们现在中国气候局。
会发预警灾害预警。
一定要关注官方的灾害预警。
然后来合理地安排自己的出行等等一些。
还有一个小的建议就是。
我们那个天气雷达图。
我们现在手机上
包括气象局
还有各种APP上。
都有实施的天气雷达图。
这个是对我们出行。
就是百灵出行的时候。
非常好的一些贪考。
网上也有很多的视频。
就是如何来看懂气象雷达图。
就是说了西红柿炒蛋。
就是打开之后
代表不同的颜色
然后西红柿就是红色的区域。
红色的区域肯定是天气最恶劣的。
你要看它离你多远。
你要做好相应的避险。
那么黄色的我们说鸡蛋。
它可能说正在发生一些强度流天气。
有可能会变得更加的严重。
就类似于这样的
这些科技的手段
我们现在周边都身边都非常的丰富。
大家一定要多看
而且一定要信
虽然它不能百分之百的准确。
但是就怕万一真正发生到我们每个人身上的时候。
我们利用它做好了紧急避险。
那可能对我们家庭幸福。
这是非常好的一种保证。
宁可信其有
而且确实从红光上这些预测都是很准确的。
不是说我今天预测下雨。
景太阳
就说没预测准
我再补充一点
怎么去看天气预报。
这是个课题
对
我们中央抢台的预报员。
包括各地的预报员。
有自己的这种集合预报。
就是我们会集合各家模式。
欧洲的美国类
然后还有中央抢台的这些模式。
然后综合去做一个研判。
然后每个公众
每个普通公众的话。
也可以有自己的集合预报。
就是大家可以看中央抢台的。
它是一个全国的一个趋势。
你要看天气系统
是不是会有一个天气系统过来。
有一个大的降水过程会过来。
你当地的话
在这些范围内的话。
就会有降水
然后你再去看我们天气APP上头。
然后它会有主小石的预报。
这是主小石的预报。
它必定准确
但是如果你看中央抢台。
它也有一个大的过程过来的话。
你就判断它
是有一次降水过程。
然后在临近的时候。
就像邵老师说的
你再去看天气雷达图。
然后雷达回播图
然后进行一个
可能几个小时之内的。
一个天气的判断
就是你去集合这几家。
这几个APP 这几个网站。
对
把这个信息综合起来。
你就会得到一个比较准确的判断。
心里就比较有底
然后你要去做一个7天的出行。
3天的出行
然后临近的出行
你就会有更多的指导意义。
感谢二位老师
今天跟我们聊这么多关于天气。
气候的问题
还真是请着了二位老师了。
因为我原先想的
可能就是一些科普的。
知识性的东西
我们今天还听到了很多。
我们在气象局
气候中心
气象中心工作的一些细节。
我们这些天气预报。
一些数据是怎么来的。
这些知识
我们还是在别处
很难听到
特别感谢二位老师。
也希望大家听完我们这期。
能对您的生活有点作用。
两位老师刚才根本分享了。
怎么去看天气预报。
在极端天气情况下。
要怎么敬畏自然躲避灾害。
这对大家来说是
切身的很重要的一方面。
也希望大家在这种。
不断的越来越怪的天气下。
能够更好的进行生产生活活动。
也希望您多听我们的播客。
把我们的知识传达出去。
同时也希望大家关注气象局。
科普中心等等
咱们气象系统这些科普。
我们兄弟单位
也是一直在尽力的。
给大家传播这种知识。
包括我们之前去的。
什么气象日的这些科普活动。
都做得非常有趣
所以大家喜欢的话。
也关注这些科普内容。
好
咱们今天就聊到这。
谢谢二位老师到来。
咱们下期再见